in March 2016 alphago beat the eighteen
time world champion
Lisa doll just one year later another
version of alphago beat itself this is
the beginning of a world of
possibilities for deep reinforcement
learning if computers can learn on their
own artificial intelligence can match
human intelligence in novel ways we've
tackled other methods of AI but you want
to be at the forefront of this field and
we've designed a deep reinforcement
learning program to get you there you
can master core skills by completing
challenging hands-on projects you'll be
set up for success through learning from
AI experts at unity and NVIDIA by the
end of the program you'll have a github
portfolio that will prepare you to build
real-world applications from finance to
robotics so join us to build artificial
intelligence that you can hardly imagine
[Music]